Tick Tock prankster who's been riling up
the internet an 18 year old by the name
of Missy according to him he's been
doing the Social Media stuff since he
was eight years old but he didn't blow
up until just two weeks ago that's
because that's when he and two of his
friends film themselves in London doing
a prank it wasn't a prank right because
what they did can only be described as a
literal home invasion his key context
here as far as we know these people are
absolute strangers
James
is this where the study group is
this no
man oh you got kids oh I thought this
was a study group I actually thought so
naturally people see this and they're
[__] furious
what did you just show me
she walked into someone's house
for a prank
and sat on the couch
he
yeah
it's just a prank bro
just a prank with many calling it
criminal demanding that he'd be arrested
even some government MPS or both parties
condemning this asking social media
companies to censor him but also with
this turns out that's not the first time
he just barged into someone's home in
another video he does the exact same
thing but instead of talking to them he
just walks around kind of Giggles like a
little school girl and then runs out I
think that might be worse
I think that objectively might be worse
walking in giggling and leaving like and
I saw little kids in there
oh
another of his famous pranks he
approaches an elderly woman just minding
her own business at a park bench and
steals her dog you got a nice dog
[Music]
I feel like this doesn't need commentary
because I think everyone sees how
[__] stupid
imagine filming yourself taking
someone's child because that's how
people view their pets in some instances
I want you guys to think about those
families who had somebody run up in
their home terrorize them and then just
run around and leave
I know have you ever had somebody do a
home invasion your home does not feel
like home and I imagine that feeling is
heightened times a hundred when there's
children he's lucky he lives in the UK I
know his dumbass wouldn't try that in
America because he'd get blasted and you
know what if he did I'd probably go piss
on his grave too and I filmed that put
that [__] on Tick Tock try to make that
a trend
piss on pranksters Graves that should be
a Tick-Tock Trend yay yes [__] this
genre and [__] these people yeah that
should be a trend and I say this to
someone who doesn't love pets I know
some people treat their pets like they
[__] children like they are that
obsessed with them I don't think that's
fine that's it imagine grabbing that and
running off and the fear and the
everything that you put that person
through yeah I don't give a [__] yeah
yeah yeah yeah you got a track record I
don't give a [__]
outside
we outside yeah you're gonna be inside
too very soon enjoy a little jail cell
stupid I'm just thinking if I can find a
bit of compassion in me I'm looking no I
have none I'm looking I'm looking for
something no no my man I'm not even
looking because I know I don't have that
product in that shelf that product is
back order when we talking about this
just walking inside someone's house
oh the things I do to you I want you
guys to take this in too the reason why
I'm saying this is because I think it's
for public good I don't even just say
this because I want to see I think it's
for public good I think these kinds of
Trends should not be encouraged because
you don't think it's not just he walked
into someone's home he filmed himself he
put on Tick Tock I made it sound like a
cool thing I imagine other people
replicating this Behavior afterwards and
how many more people it might affect
plenty of others just kind of a
scattered shot whether it's him
appearing to tear up a book at a library
or him just asking random women if they
want to die wow
yup
whoa [__] he got arrested and then he
got released he put He got put on
probation meaning he couldn't do any
more videos at first many young people
see social media stardom as a fast track
to Fame and Fortune people you've never
heard of can become very famous and very
wealthy very quickly from the business
of banking clicks and followers online
but with more than 500 hours of content
uploaded every single minute just to
YouTube how do they even begin to get
noticed or some influences have a talent
they can sing or dance some give Brash
opinions some play computer games some
of your friendly tutorials on things I
had to do makeup or make music but
others get their clicks by honestly
behaving like complete morons in
California a YouTuber and pilot faced 20
years in jail for crashing an airplane
to get more subscribers others have
jumped from City buildings taken on wild
animals
20 years to get subscribers 20 years in
prison to get subscribers never mind how
[__] dangerous to crash a plane
because you're assuming that you're
going to get all your calculations
proper you're going to crash it into
Wildlife which is still dangerous
because you might set a forest fire
whatever
you did that for [__] subscribers
what a loser instead of having like real
skills or kind of personality or
Charisma or just take time to make
really interesting projects you decide
to put everybody's lives at [__]
risks including all kinds of Wildlife
for subscribers like that is how
addicted people are to social media
attention
I keep thinking of that thing it was
like Charlie Murphy where it's like
cocaine's a hell of a drug yeah tick
tock's ahead of a drug clout is a hell
of a drug his name is a hell of a drug
social media addiction is wild well
there's public anger grew this week
London's met police announced they were
looking for Missy real name bakari
bronzagaro the law caught up with him
yes and today he was fine 365 pounds and
given a criminal Behavior order which is
supposed to ban him from posting to
social media without the written
permission of the people in his videos
you might think that's not much of a
punishment or much of a deterrent well
what does he think well fresh from the
courtroom he's here now all right well
good evening to you hello hello pears
long time no see it's been a long time
no see last time I hopped on your thing
with my friend
that's right you're paid in the
background yeah
okay well I've got your mate um what I
am as an interviewer
um his personality is even shittier than
his pranks yeah I didn't thought that
was possible
I'm watching the interview with Piers
Morgan in him and I'm like it appears a
hundred times more so you could already
imagine we have to a [__] up start
when we feel when we feel bad for a
period yay when we that's what you [__]
I mean I don't feel bad for peers
because that's his job but I definitely
feel he's more sympathetic God damn
curious about what has been motivated
you to terrorize the people around where
you live I wouldn't really call it
terrorizing I'll just call it more
having fun but let's get this out of the
way first not stupid it's fun for you
it's Terror for other people you think
that woman was having fun when you stole
her [__] dog
she just go walk up to a random woman
and ask them if they wanted to see this
is my thing with pricer and that's fun
this is my thing with pranksters it's
content for you for other people it's
real life they don't know this [__]
they're not taking it as that that woman
that you went and said that [__] to you
don't know what she been through in
terms of walking out the streets you
know how many people get harassed on a
regular basis I have to deal with
[__] and then they come up to you
and then all of a sudden you tell them
Yo do you want to lose your life you
don't know how that's going to mentally
affect them for the rest of their lives
you're not just oh I'm behind you it's a
prank bro no the way that you guys set
up these [__] pranks is that you try
to traumatize people
and then you turn into your own content
it's fun for you it's fun for your
viewers it's not fun for the people
involved
the people who don't make a dime offer
the people who actually suffer gift Rob
they throw the book at this [__]
but it's the UK so you already know
they're gonna give him a brownie some
tea and a Pat in the back yeah they say
long live the queen tell his [__] ass
to get out the back I apologize you see
this situation I blew up on the Internet
walking into random houses
the next day I apologize to the woman
because I felt bad in it like beeping on
social media like it went deeper than
social media that's why I didn't record
it she recorded me apologizing to her I
told her sorry and she explained that
she was terrified because like children
were in the house and I understand what
are they doing in the house
there's a Dean in the house I don't know
it was a stupid video like I got peer
pressure to see I want to say it like in
that way but somebody else is full I
don't blame you know no one else I mean
you're breaking that house with it with
a with a woman and a husband on my own
accord no I'm just saying okay you went
through their door
bro rewatch that video the second time
it almost feels worse
so once you guys to think about the
[__] fighting flight
feeling you get when you're in your
house and you look at your doorway and
there's somebody inside who's not
supposed to be there coming into your
home you guys ever dealt with that
because I have
it's instant panic mode
that's why
me parsley I sleep is with a weapon
beside my bed every night every night
not because I think something's gonna
happen but if it does I just want to be
ready because I've already had stuff
happen before
this man doing this I can already tell
for the man on the other side the one
who owns the home and you can see his
child behind him and his head a lot of
things are going through it I want you
guys to think about how [__] up it is
to make someone go through that right
but it's not your house you're not
supposed to be in there oh no you are
causing a lot of alarm to that poor
woman and to her children who are in the
house enter the man I think it's also
important to say like I understand like
in these kind of situations we always
think about how women and children are
affected but make no mistake
it is terrifying even for men
there's nobody who gets their home
broken into irrespective of gender and
doesn't feel violated you then terrorize
this poor elderly woman and take a dog
away and traumatize her the story about
that
yeah
no no no no no I'm going to tell you let
me talk about it no wait a minute wait a
minute for the viewers wait a minute for
the viewers we don't know what you've
done hold on I'm going to tell them no
you hold on right now no you can hold on
right now I'm explaining I'm explaining
you know what's been happening don't
just keep talking like an idiot I right
don't let me finish what the viewers
don't know you did I you go up and you
do these things you take a dog from an
elderly woman you Leap Frog over the top
of an Orthodox Jewish man standing at
the side of the road mining his own
business you go up to women in the
street and say do you want to die it
wasn't a woman it was a man there were
also women
there but I only say it to the Man
chicken out man do you think it's better
to say that to men
[Applause]
the gender thing but it keeps popping up
because I see this like do you think a
man wants to hear do you want to and
they're going to be fine with it
mentally
maybe I'm unaware maybe there's like a
societal perception that men can just
tolerate this kind of stuff and not be
affected yeah it's fine we're good
and these are men's challenges these are
men saying this right you shouldn't be
saying it to anybody fair enough why are
you why in the name of so-called
prankster humor why cause so much alarm
and distress to so many people do you
get your kicks out of doing that not
necessarily but you can say that this
whole public outro just makes me laugh
because people are getting hurt over
something that didn't happen to them and
that's how I see us what do you mean oh
my god you're an idiot I don't know if
you're a sociopath or if you don't you
can't connect stuff in your brain or if
you got a drop on your head as a child
so there's something there or you just
don't have any emotion or you lack
empathy or I don't know or you're on the
spec I don't know what it is Tick Tock
break Jesus
how old is this dude how old is he 18.
and you know what the age doesn't really
change now change nothing why are you
talking to anybody in that way why am I
targeting anyone it was a trend it was a
trend I just done it for a trend what's
the trend what's the trend oh jump over
someone at the time of the beat however
much you scare them how however I'm
actually scared him or even if you push
them into a car no that's that didn't
happen though because I saw it didn't
happen but it didn't happen but it
didn't happen a lot of the stuff that
you do and it could have consequences
far more serious but you don't care do
you because if you notice when he jumps
on the guy goes onto the street it could
have happened that he got hit by a car
because of what you did that could have
been the consequence him running away
from you could have resulted in him
because you literally see him running
onto the middle of the street you're
lucky there was no cars at that
intersection listen Lizzy
um if you're listening oh he can't
listen he's back in jail oh yeah he
broke his court order what do you do he
was back on tick tock
I'm telling you it's a hell of a drug
I'm gonna tell you this
um
when you get out hopefully you don't the
thing that happened is this whenever you
get a sentence yeah they actually
evaluate
what could have happened
the consequences not only that happened
but what could have happened they
actually include that in your sentence
and if what could have happened could
have been really sorry it could have
been really messed up or could have
killed someone
it can actually affect your sentence and
that's that's that's life
your life is going to be like that so
your whole argument about it didn't
happen well
doesn't really work like that
sometimes you get a lot I have remorse I
have remorsefulness
do you live in my life are you there for
my parents have you been there what's
your life tell me you tell me my life
presumably are you about life you
presumably you're about to tell me the
sob story what's the sub story there's
no sauce
what's so bad about your life in it I I
just do it for fun on or off camera I do
my team tell me about your life what
justifies this what's happened to you
that makes you think you're justified in
doing this what do you tell me about my
life well you said you said you're
learning about your life tell me about
yourself because I'm black because I
guarantee it because you're black yeah I
guarantee if I don't give a damn about
your skin color
no
what no that was not it my guy I don't
even know where
you instigated this
you said you don't know about you don't
know about my life and he's like what's
the sob story that explained that
behavior if I do not know about your
life had nothing oh my God
context people you don't even gotta
explain everybody's sorry
you ain't gotta explain that one context
people
jeez
all right I don't want to keep watching
this is watching when when okay when's
the time where he kicks him out did he
kick him out no not all right
um
you guys know how I feel about
pranksters I don't want to rehash that I
think they're a blight in society I
think vast majority of them are trash
and uh I think I look forward to the day
where YouTube Outlaws that kind of
content because you shouldn't be able to
monetize terrorizing other people
I just don't think you should
and I think these Trends need to be
nipped in the butt because apparently
young people are too [__] not to
follow a trend that harms other folks
and so yeah I'm not mad at social media
platforms taking charge we shouldn't
create platforms where it encourages
people to run up in people's homes we
shouldn't create platforms what
encourages people to grab random strings
and try to jump over them we shouldn't
encourage that
are you talking about censorship in the
platform for [__] like this yeah yeah if
basically on your platform was getting
popular okay he's people harming other
people and it's growing viral and
getting more young people to do it I'm
not mad at people getting rid of that
[__] no maybe that's a crazy take and
maybe I don't see the ways in which what
I'm saying right now is actually going
to have a negative impact but
I think allowing this kind of stuff is
worse I mean that's my take
that's crazy that people really love
that yeah it is I wouldn't know that
either
it's crazy and you're not seeing it
I think it's a new thing you're right
addiction to clout is a thing definitely
a thing for you to break everything to
go back to whatever you're not supposed
to do and then you go back to that to do
jail at 18.
we were growing up [__] was
going to jail for drugs and beating
people up these people are going to jail
because they can't put down their cell
phone tick tock
all right